pour la lection fr
[Musique]
tout le monde a entendu parler de Patty Hurse pour la première fois
la nuit où elle a été kidnappée Trisha
Campbell Hurst, une étudiante de 19 ans a été
emmenée de son appartement et son fiancé
Steven Weed a été battu et a dû être
hospitalisé
Patricia Hurst vivait dans un quartier calme
quartier aisé de Berkeley, elle a été
traînée dans la rue par les hommes qui
étaient armés de fusils. Son fiancé a dit
depuis son lit d'hôpital aujourd'hui que les
ravisseurs ont agi comme
des commandos. Maman papa. Je vais
bien,
j'ai choisi de me battre contre
les  Le premier cas couvert par les
médias après l'
enlèvement était le vol de la
banque Hiberia, elle était dans la banque, elle avait une
mitrailleuse, la seule question était si
elle était là volontairement ou était-elle là
parce qu'ils la tueraient
[Musique]
vite, je
m'appelle  Francis Lee Bailey Jr mais je
suis connu dans la plupart des pays sous le nom de F Lee
Bailey, un avocat de la défense pénale, un
avocat de la défense privé F Le
Bailey est une superstar une série d'
acquittements criminels célèbres derrière lui, il est
flamboyant, il vole, son propre hélicoptère
manipule la presse, j'ai défendu Patty
Hurst et  euh, un peu plus tard, OJ
Simpson, donc j'ai été assez
occupé pendant les années 60, il y a eu
beaucoup de soulèvements rebelles parmi les
jeunes, en commençant peut-être par le
festival de Woodstock qui était paisible
mais il y a eu beaucoup de
troubles et dans les années 70, il y a eu un certain nombre de
des groupes radicaux qui
s'imaginaient servir les États-Unis
en brûlant des
drapeaux et cela a reçu beaucoup de nouvelles mais
a également causé beaucoup de dégâts et c'est
là que Patty Hurst
a éclaté
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
la
Patty Hurst était un  une jeune femme très riche,
complètement
banale, n'a jamais eu d'
ennuis, euh, ce n'était pas la plus grande gueule
de sa
famille
[Musique],
par
exemple, il y
avait un groupe appelé The
SLA et leur chef qui s'appelait "
chante mignon", ces gens avaient toujours de bons
noms pour eux-mêmes et il  j'aimais
causer des ennuis et je veux dire de gros ennuis,
mon nom est péché Q Je suis un homme noir et un
représentant des Noirs utilisant de
vraies armes Dynamite, tirant sur des gens
braquant des banques, faisant exploser des commissariats de police
et plaçant des bombes sous des voitures de police,
donc ce gamin n'était pas un délinquant juvénile,
il l'était  un criminel très dangereux et il
avait beaucoup de
partisans notre objectif unifié est de
libérer les peuples opprimés de cette
nation et le vol de leur
liberté et de
leur patrie un avertissement à l'
État militaire fasciste, nous avons déclaré la guerre révolutionnaire
contre vous, l'ennemi du
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gens, la demande de rançon tant attendue
de la part de l'Armée de libération Symbian
est enfin arrivée et avec elle une cassette de
la voix de Patty Hurst Maman Papa, je vais
bien
[Musique] euh j'ai eu
quelques égratignures et tout ça mais
euh ils se sont lavés  ils se lèvent et ils vont
bien et j'ai attrapé un rhume mais ils
me donnent des pilules pour ça et
donc je ne suis pas affamé, ni battu,
ni effrayé inutilement,
euh, j'ai entendu des articles de presse et donc
je sais que  Steve et tous les voisins
sont d'accord sur le fait que personne n'a été vraiment
blessé. C'est donc la directive de
ce tribunal qu'un acte de bonne foi
soit démontré de la part de la
famille Hearst. Ce geste doit être sous la forme
d'un imbécile envers les nécessiteux et  les
chômeurs l'armée de limitation Sim
essayait de se positionner un peu comme
Robin des Bois voler les riches donner aux
pauvres un M. et Mme Hurst extrêmement désemparés ont
parlé directement à leur fille
ce
matin nous t'aimons Patty et nous
prions tous pour toi  Je connais ces gens qui
avaient de bons idéaux, ils les abordent dans
le mauvais sens Patty J'espère que tu
écoutes,
c'est un peu effrayant parce que la
demande initiale est ce dont j'avais peur
depuis le début, c'est celle qui est
impossible à
satisfaire
cependant  euh dans les prochaines 24 48 heures, je
ferai de mon mieux pour revenir avec
une sorte de contre-
offre euh c'est
[Applaudissements]
acceptable
[Musique]
messieurs J'aime juste faire cette
déclaration Des dispositions ont été prises
pour 2
millions de dollars pour  être
livrés à une organisation caritative exonérée d'impôt
pour ce montant, un demi-
million de dollars représente mon propre fonds,
pensez-vous qu'ils seront envoyés
également, je le suis, c'est un geste de bonne volonté,
il n'y a aucune garantie que Patricia
rentrera chez elle avec cela  C'est un
effort honnête de ma part pour faire ce que je peux et
c'est tout ce que je peux faire. Je pense que c'est à
eux maintenant de me croire et,
espérons-le, de faire un geste de leur
part,
mais le plan de distribution de nourriture a été mal
géré par le SLA.  a dit dans une cassette ultérieure que le
cadeau était une imposture, hé mec, j'étais
foutu, ce qu'ils ont fait mec, ils ont jeté la nourriture
dans le camion, ils auraient dû le
faire, c'était fou, c'était vraiment
fou
[Musique]
Papa, je sais que tu as eu le plus  de la nourriture
donnée aux personnes dans le besoin et que vous
avez investi très peu d'argent dans
le
programme. Je ne crois pas que vous
fassiez tout ce que vous pouvez, tout ce qui est en
votre pouvoir. Je ne crois pas que vous
fassiez quoi que ce soit.  si vous aviez
fait ce que voulait la SLA avec le
programme alimentaire, le mois serait presque terminé
et je serais prêt à sortir de
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
ici [
mec
[Applaudissements]
Je n'ai jamais été obligé de dire  quoi que ce soit
sur aucune cassette et je n'ai pas subi de lavage de cerveau,
drogué, torturé, hypnotisé ou confus de quelque
manière que ce soit
quant à mon ex-
fian au cours des derniers mois, Steven
s'est révélé être un porc sexiste et agressif.
Je suis étonné qu'il pense que la
première chose que je  ce que je voudrais faire une fois
libéré serait de me précipiter et de le voir le
fait est que je m'en fiche si je le revois un jour
je pense qu'il est clair qu'elle l'est elle
lit quelque chose que quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
a écrit c'est moi comme je veux  tel que
je le vois,
j'ai eu le choix entre un
être libéré dans une zone sûre ou deux
rejoignant les forces de l'
Armée de libération Symbian et luttant pour ma
liberté et celle de tous les
peuples opprimés. J'ai choisi de rester et de
combattre.  J'ai reçu le
laissez-
passer [Musique] [
Musique]
salutations aux gens, voici
Tanya, le 15 avril, mes camarades et moi avons
exproprié
10 000 $ de la banque Hiberia. J'étais
positionné de manière à pouvoir retenir
les clients et le personnel de la banque qui étaient à
l'étage.  mon arme était
chargée, je suis un soldat dans les bras du peuple
[Musique] [
Musique]
était [
Musique] [
Musique]
Patricia son nom C était Tanya avait une
mitrailleuse et quand une banque a été braquée,
ils aiment mettre Patty juste
devant  une dispute pour que la presse et tout le
monde voient que c'était elle le
15 avril cinq membres de la SLA ont
dévalisé la banque Hiberia à San Francisco
deux personnes ont été abattues lors du vol
le gang de la SLA s'est enfui avec plus de
110 000 $ le vol a été filmé  D'après les
caméras automatiques de la banque, le FBI a déclaré que la fille à la perruque
et au fusil automatique était Patricia
Hurst. J'étais positionné de manière à pouvoir
retenir les clients et le personnel de la banque qui
étaient au sol. Mon arme était
chargée personnellement. Je n'y crois pas.
Je l'ai eu
20 ans, ils l'ont eu 60
jours et je ne crois pas qu'elle
va changer sa philosophie si
rapidement ou de façon permanente et
je ne le croirai jamais
[Musique]
e
je m'appelle  Tom Matthews, euh, j'ai 65
ans, j'avais 18 ans le 16 mai 1974
lorsque j'ai rencontré Patty Hurst dans la
SLA [Musique]
il y a de nombreuses années, n'aimeriez-vous pas
y revenir dans un petit instant
ouais pendant une minute CU tu as la
même apparence que toi Je te choisirais
[Musique]
Je pense que le plus c'était à quel point nous
avions peur cette nuit-là, tu ne savais même pas que nous
avions si peur ouais ouais nous pensions que tu
ne pourrais pas, nous pourrions  je ne te reverrai pas, je pensais que
tu l'étais,
je pensais que tu étais peut-être
mort,
ouais, heureusement, nous t'avons
récupéré, tu sais, ouais, il était environ 19 heures
et on a frappé à ma
porte et c'était une femme qui voulait faire un essai
routier.  ma camionnette j'avais une Ford une camionnette conine
à vendre alors elle m'a demandé si elle pouvait tester
la
camionnette ouais et elle a juste parcouru un pâté de maisons et a
tourné le coin et s'est arrêtée et j'ai vu
une voiture garée de l'autre côté de la rue et elle a
demandé si ses amis pouvaient  Je suis venu lors
de l'essai routier et j'étais plutôt insouciant.
J'ai dit que bien sûr, pas de
problème, le seul monsieur qui est venu le
découvrir était William
Harris, il a ouvert ma porte, puis il a
ouvert son manteau et il avait une
mitrailleuse, il a dit que si je le faisais  Je ne ferais rien de
bizarre, je ne serais pas blessé et ma
réponse immédiate fut que tant que je
ne me faisais pas tirer dessus, je me fichais de ce qui
se passait et puis la dernière personne
est entrée et euh il l'a montrée du doigt et elle a eu
un  perruque noire bouclée et il a dit,
savez-vous qui c'est et j'ai dit
non, il a dit que c'était
Tanya et à cause de toutes les émissions d'information
que j'avais vues, je savais que c'était
Patty Hurst et mes premiers mots
sortis de ma bouche étaient  mes amis ne
vont pas croire cette
histoire car ils sont venus me chercher à 7h00 nous avons
roulé un peu
pendant que nous parlions de sport parce que je
leur ai dit que j'avais un match de baseball le
lendemain et ensuite je leur ai demandé pourquoi ils
avaient volé la banque Hiberia  Parce que c'était la
vraie photo célèbre d'elle tenant la
mitrailleuse, ils m'ont dit qu'ils menaient une
guerre civile contre le gouvernement des États-Unis,
ils avaient besoin d'argent et
c'est à ce moment-là qu'elle
m'a dit qu'elle participait volontairement
au vol de banque dans lequel
Patty se trouvait.  la camionnette avec moi parce qu'elle
n'arrêtait pas de me tapoter, elle l'était, je pouvais
dire qu'elle était inquiète que j'avais
peur parce qu'elle pouvait en quelque sorte imaginer
quand elle a été kidnappée ce qu'elle ressentait alors
elle essayait de
me réconforter et Patty Hurst m'a en fait donné  un
petit bisou sur la joue
euh et donc cette nuit-là, quand nous sommes allés
dormir dans le van, ils m'ont donné une
couverture parce qu'ils savaient que je ne me
sentais pas bien alors ils ont dit ici Tom,
tu sais que tu prends la couverture et ainsi  ils
ont été gentils avec moi, ils m'ont offert de l'
argent pour l'essence, alors quand je me suis réveillé le matin,
William Harris était à l'arrière de la
camionnette avec moi et il m'a vaguement menacé,
il a en quelque sorte dit que non, je n'étais pas
obligé de le faire.  J'ai dit à la police tout ce que
je savais, ils savaient où j'habitais mais
je ne me sentais pas
menacé et c'est pour ça que
quand ils m'ont quitté parce qu'ils avaient détourné
un autre véhicule le matin et j'ai donc
conduit jusqu'à chez moi.  Je suis entré dans
ma maison et ma petite amie maintenant, ma femme
Susan avait passé la nuit
chez moi, les choses auraient pu mal tourner
mais comme je l'ai dit, le bon Dieu avait un plan
pour nous ouais c'est vrai cinq petits-enfants
trois enfants maintenant nous avons juste tout
ça  laisser derrière moi Je ne sais pas si
quelqu'un comprend vraiment la gravité de
cette affaire à moins de l'avoir vécu.
J'étais un peu soulagé que tu saches que
la soirée était terminée et que j'ai pu
retourner à ma, euh, ma
vie, euh, j'ai dormi pendant  environ 4 heures
alors je vais jouer mon match de baseball donc
le match a commencé vers
15h30 et puis c'est environ une demi-
heure plus tard, c'est quand la fusillade a
commencé, la grande
fusillade enflammée, voyons si nous ne pouvions toujours pas
obtenir ça  photo mais d'un
endroit un peu meilleur, hein, eh bien, je ne sais pas si
c'est une bonne idée d'interviewer quelqu'un
maintenant, nous avons juste pris une balle à quelques
centimètres environ parce que nous l'avons sentie Passez, nous l'avons sentie
Passez, c'est pour Hur et j'ai entendu
et c'est aussi proche que je veux en être
un, laissez-moi vous le dire, donc tout le monde était
collé à la télévision en train de regarder la
fusillade et et à ce moment-là, tout le monde
pensait que Patty était dans la maison
[Musique]
J'étais anxieux, j'aurais détesté
si pour savoir qu'elle était dans cette
maison alors ils ont fait une vérification du dossier dentaire
et c'était soit samedi tard,
soit dimanche matin, ils ont annoncé qu'elle
n'était pas dans la maison qu'elle était
encore
en vie
salutations aux gens c'est
Tanya c'est difficile  pour expliquer ce que c'était de
voir nos camarades mourir, je suis mort dans
cet incendie sur la 54ème rue mais de mes
cendres je suis né de nouveau, je sais ce que je dois
faire, la vie m'est très précieuse car j'ai
choisi de vivre le reste de ma vie
entouré de  les porcs comme les
Hursts, la mort de l'insecte fasciste qui
prévaut sur la vie des
gens, il n'y a pas
de reddition
le jour où ils ont attrapé Patty Hurst, elle a salué
d'un poing fermé
et s'est présentée comme un gorille urbain
[Musique] dont
nous avons eu une conversation très heureuse
Questions de famille et les amis
dont elle a parlé, était-elle heureuse de vous voir,
oh bien sûr, elle l'était, nous lui avons dit que
nous l'aimions, nous l'avons serrée dans nos bras et l'avons
embrassée,
merci, vous avez tous été
merveilleux. J'étais assis chez une femme.
prison, quand le directeur m'a apporté son
téléphone personnel, il a dit qu'il y avait un homme
au téléphone qui prétendait être Randy et
il voulait te parler et à ce moment-là,
tout le monde attendait de
savoir qui serait son avocat.
[Musique]
serait privé  l'avocat de la défense F Lee Bailey
est une superstar une série d'
acquittements criminels célèbres derrière lui il est
flamboyant vole son propre hélicoptère
manipule la presse à quel point
pensez-vous que c'est un avantage pour Patty d'avoir
un avocat de premier plan de quoi
dépend son succès  que cela dépend
principalement de son témoignage et que tout
avocat qui avait un témoin aussi bon qu'elle
et qui n'a pas pu convaincre un jury qu'elle
disait la vérité n'aurait pas
fait du bon
travail, l'affaire TVH était la pire affaire que j'ai
jamais connue  J'ai dû gérer
parce que partout où vous vous tourniez, il y avait
un autre crime, un attentat à la bombe, des policiers
tirant avec une mitrailleuse sur une foule, deux
vols de banque, si je me défendais dans un cas, cela tombait sur de
mauvaises
preuves, dans un autre cas, c'était un
cauchemar, il était tôt cette fois-ci.  matin, lorsque
Patricia Hurst est arrivée au
palais de justice du comté d'Alam ici à Oakland, maintenant
habillée modestement, parfois au bord des larmes,
elle raconte au jury les horreurs de l'
enlèvement d'être terrifiée
et soumise à un lavage de cerveau. Son avocat dit par la SLA que c'est la vérité ou est-ce qu'elle ment une
partie importante de  subir un lavage de cerveau, c'est
que votre QI
diminue jusqu'à ce que vous
récupériez la première réunion, elle
n'a probablement pas dit 10 mots, elle était toute
blottie dans un petit cocon et elle s'est juste assise
là, elle a juste souri et a hoché la
tête.
[Musique] l'
avocat fle Bailey a mis  sa version de
la défense de Patricia Hurst simplement et
peut-être littéralement aujourd'hui, quelqu'un m'a mis une
arme sur la tempe et j'ai fait ce qu'ils m'ont dit
de faire notre défense, c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont dit, sortez
un peu de la ligne, nous allons
vous faire exploser la tête, sortez de la ligne  deux
petits morceaux, les flics vous feront exploser la tête
[Musique]
bien que condamnée à 7 ans
Patricia Hurst n'aura pas à purger
la totalité de sa peine, elle a déjà passé
un an en prison pour lequel elle sera
créditée et elle deviendra éligible
à la libération conditionnelle en  16
mois, l'affaire n'a été un succès que sur
un
point. J'ai été embauché pour l'empêcher de
passer le reste de sa vie derrière
les barreaux, elle n'a passé que trois ans en
prison, ce qui s'appelle le
succès
[Musique] [Musique
]
pour
[Musique]
oh
[  Musique]
bien portion d'alment